if he can change a tire maybe he can
change the world well that went great
yeah it's this choreographed as the Ice
Capades but it beats watching his
feverish lightweight clipping his ear
hair cutting out some of this ear hair
that you get when you get older it grows
out of your ears you know you don't get
it cut or dragging you to the dentist to
see the inside of his gaping mouth so
I'm here at the dentist and we're going
to continue our series on the people of
the border oh so what's next for Slender
Man
what other impersonations of a regular
guy can he do
can he hammer a nail into the coffin of
his dead campaign or dig a ditch where
he can bury the unsold copies of Vanity
Fair maybe return home to borrow money
from the in-laws meanwhile Liz gets an
earful of reality from a farmer the
green new deal sells we need to get rid
of cows I don't agree with that the
truth left are called as Kamala finds no
rest in a rest home
then she threw her behind bars
well that was bad why is that well
neither Liz or Kamala seem interested or
comfortable and bado proves he's not
only unqualified to be President but
student body president - then there's
Trump love him or hate him he's achieved
one great thing that by comparison he
makes every politician who still acts
like one look kind of phony Trump right
off the bat said I'm not kissing any
babies and never let his unique
personality become subservient to
political fakery so everyone else who
plays this game since Trump looks weird
or desperate you'd think they'd figure
this out by now you aren't gonna beat
Trump with let's pretend we're real you
win by being real too bad that's not an
option for the Dems the only real people
they see these have seemed to be ignored
or mocked like Mary Ann the others
cookie cutter clones and Trump he's the
Cookie Monster that's the thing is Dana
everybody just kind of looks fake Trump
broke that seal and it can't ever be the
same and there's only one person on that
battlefield that can match him and I
think we know who that is marianne
williamson she's not pretending to be
anybody she's the real deal and she's
fighting a psychological battle which
makes you're different than all those
others well the interesting thing about
all of what you just said is that the
backfiring exposes their vulnerabilities
yeah right so on on the healthcare piece
with Kamala Harris there's been a
questionable wait what are you really
for and how can you say you're going to
do these things without messing up
something else you can when you're
talking to about healthcare to a senior
citizen they love their Medicare and
they don't believe that their Medicare
will remain the same if you provide
Medicare for all right they know that
that isn't possible
Beto has this problem of not looking
authentic or like being sort of like a
gimmick yeah and
let's just set last week aside in El
Paso because I think that obviously it's
different but the you know the the the
stunts that he did with that the dentist
and then you have Lauren like her
left-wing agenda is pretty much dead on
arrival in Middle America so everything
that you pointed out is actually
targeting zeroing in on their biggest
vulnerabilities yeah okay sure what can
they do at markets it seems like they're
think they can't figure it out they're
you know they're kind of in a pickle I
think one of the great things that Trump
did was destroy the fakeness of American
presidential campaigning which I hate
this business where they they try to
demonstrate their authenticity by we
know baito doesn't change Tyler I
wouldn't want to be doing 140 miles an
hour down a German Autobahn in a vehicle
that had had its tires done by beta
anyway so why are you German are away
mark it's a crazy state in many ways one
of the things about Trump was he didn't
pretend I am it's a bipartisan thing I
live in New Hampshire we don't get the
my pillow ads we just get these
political ads all the time so we have
John Kasich going I'm proud to say I was
born the son of a mailman
he was a Lehman brother when Lehman
Brothers when he was he's the brother of
a Lehman when Lehman Brothers went south
he was on the board I'm proud to say was
the son I wanted your friend Jeb Bush at
that time to UM buy pad say I grew up
the son of a president we we had it
tough back then we only have the 20 car
motorcade not the 40 car mod a cage like
they got now you know this is Trump
destroyed all that you can't go back to
it yeah one what about I mean the most
authentic person behind Marianne is
Bernie right he's the real deal first of
all the first of all I'm stunned it's
done thank you doctor got bail is now
the biggest marianne williamson fan in
you know why because you think she's a
joke this is a total you are that you've
been but your voice there my reading is
for weeks and thereby meeting yeah and
it's not in your reading it incorrectly
I know I'm because I'm always wrong so
let me just say that humanizing
politicians is American as apple pie
since I have covered politics it's
always been there right that in fact if
you're a political consultant and you
don't tell your candidate to get human
to see authentic yeah they're not a
political consultant and if I think
somebody told Donald Trump oh why don't
you hire young people to stand around
while you go down that golden escalator
to instruct them to put on t-shirts and
to wave yeah I believe that's what
happened a protester great it's a TV
show it's always gonna be a TV show for
Trump well that's what he did so I don't
know about he's not here
oh he's natural natural remember who had
taco taco Bowl on Cinco de Maya oh gee I
think that was that was it it's worthy
okay cute one do you know who Trump
doesn't talk about Marianne Williamson
oh yeah here we go talk about her
because early on you you and I think it
was one of the debates you said she's
the only one up there that is actually
talking to people in a language that
they can understand yes and it did the
good thing about her is that you know
she says you can't out walk any it ball
right but remember she said Trump is
darkness and hatred and you gotta come
with love and light I'm telling you know
would want that is a cohesive argument
it's all about performance I mean it's
not about substance and that's Trump a
person actors about persuasion
jet I get why they want to seem
relatable like remember President Obama
he was the guy that everybody wanted to
have a beer with the first really sad
that you need consultants to tell these
dollars seems to be an act human but I
think it's a problem because they're not
actually portraying it would be fine if
beta we're out there doing something
that was authentic that he actually did
day to day I mean he changes a tire the
way I change a tire it's pretty obvious
everybody so and they're tripping over
their own feet I think you see it with
Joe Biden they're tripping over their
own feet to try to figure out what their
voters want and you're right this would
work if you were running I think this
would work running against someone like
a Mitt Romney I think it would work
running against someone who was this
pre-programmed candidate who sat with
consultants and got lectured about how
to be human but they're running against
the guy who won by just saying whatever
he has to say being himself sometimes
he's not politically correct so it
doesn't work so they should spend less
time trying to do this and more time
trying to figure out like hey who are we
running against and if we actually win
what are we gonna look like trying so
hard
standing next to a guy on stage who
isn't trying to do anything at all but
just say what he's got to say oh yeah
that's why he walks up behind Hillary
Clinton and looks like these things he
keeps pressing the fear but he they say
he makes it the Democrats are so not
done he makes mistakes one he puts his
mouth at times but it's real yeah he has
that feel of when you sit around your
dinner table on a holiday and you've got
your uncle or whoever talking he's got
that feel of this is how he will feel
that's why that's why when I sit around
my chair and tell me you know what I do
I get all the women who've accused Bill
Clinton of sexual impropriety together
and have a panel yeah that's what I do
and it works so authentic of you Donald
yeah but no it's a show for him but he's
an authentic show me